and so you know like I get a lot of
criticism if you didn't know I mean I
got entire websites devoted to hating on
how stupid Dave Ramsey is the REMS is
good at getting people out of that but
he doesn't know anything about investing
and all this bunch of crap and you know
the people saying I got a net worth of
$4 you know it's just it and Dave Ramsey
says you can get 12% oh look the phone
bill where you can get 12% well I mean
oh yeah just go online and do a little
bit of research you can find mutual
funds that have averaged over 12% I mean
mine do and this year I don't know but
I'll talk about over a long period of
time long track records which is how I
teach you to analyze investing and yes I
do know something about I've got you
know millions and millions of dollars
people I didn't accidentally get that
money and I didn't inherit any of it so
you know you know new rims uses you can
get 12% see now you're arguing over the
difference in 12 and 11 are the
difference in 12 and 10 you know where
you're you and good 10 listen if you
can't find 10% average on a 10 or 20
year track record on a mutual fund you
need to get out of the investment
business I mean you should get if you're
that stupid you should get away from the
business and so you know but again the
point is not 10 the point is not 12
the point is put money in the freaking
investment that's the big deal it's all
about savings rate meaning you actually
put money in there did you put in 10
percent of your income 20 percent of
your income 15 percent of your income
steadily from age 30 to age 60 if you
did you probably got well in excess of a
million dollars if you invested in good
equities as he said good growth stock
mutual funds like we teach that's really
what you do that's all there is to this
and and you don't have to have a
master's degree in finance to be able to
retire with dignity you don't have to
you know have you know some kind of
pocket protector for your pins because
you're such a nerd and a fanny pack and
I'm you know a calculator on your belt
clip in order to retire with dignity you
just
have to put money in the investment 74%
of the relative importance of the driver
of retirement success by this piece of
research shows rate of savings savings
rate it's more important than the rate
of return it's more important than the
expenses associated with the investment
it's more important than anything having
to do with investing 3/4 of the reason
you succeed is that you actual with
money is you actually put money in the
investment see that is a behavior and
you can the good news is is this really
is not rocket science you can do this
and so you can win that way now
obviously if you put it in something
gives you a good rate of return you're
going to have a better rate of success
lower expenses you're gonna have a
better rate of success but those are
lesser indicators of your future success
than actually freakin doing it this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
you
[Music]